when should a producer quit their job
whatever their day job was or night job
was to focus on being a film producer
entirely when do they feel like or when
do you feel like that's a safe
transition yeah
it's really hard to be safe when
transitioning from something of
structure or stability to being a
producer unless you're going to you got
a job you were hired at a studio or
something like that it's a hard thing
but if you're coming from the
independent world and you're like I'm
about to venture out and just do this
it's really hard to establish a safe
thing I think wisdom is the most
important thing wisdom within a place
that could be very dangerous for one
whatever your profession is or whatever
you're making your money in see if you
can continue making that money while
still doing it and if you say I can't
find out why like is it a money problem
a time problem is it a capacity problem
because it's gonna look so green on this
side of like I get to live out my dreams
and I even work with somebody right now
where they're like I just can't wait
talking to quit my job and I'm like yes
but then this that seems so perfect even
when they come to set we're stressed
they're like this is great I'm like yeah
but when this is your thing and
everything is dependent on it that
stress it's something that you're gonna
experience higher than your job because
there's no there's no net there so just
be aware of why like why is it that I
feel that I can't do my job still and do
this so then come up with a plan so for
me I was doing events and I never had
that cushion I always said I don't know
who living on the dangerous side I
always had contracts and I didn't have a
job I always had that but you know with
events you get that one client that just
keeps hey can you do this can you do
that it's great so I had that but those
clients I couldn't do you know I
produced a lot of big events and then I
also did personnel management for like
US Open just to give an idea of the high
level
amount of pressure or importance of me
being there right so to remove myself
from that I had to save money and that
money that I saved was enough if
something went bad I could have money to
exist on before I went and did something
elsa makes the money like it's that
that's money and that's different for
everyone you gotta really take an
account of what your life is I live way
below my means always that's something I
learned from my dad being this Jamaican
man but what I what do I need to survive
and what do I need to survive for six
months six months like if something went
bad I didn't get to the six months I
didn't have a little nest egg that big
but I was able to have like a solid like
say four put away because four months
I'm scrappy if things go bad I can find
some money in four months you know so to
put some money away the where if
something went bad or didn't work out
don't have a safety net where you're
gonna quit but have a safety net where
you can still figure it out you don't
have to just fall apart and then go work
at a soup kitchen I don't know this is
something you know so that and then
figure out who is your support system in
this next venture because a lot of times
we think again it's so green on that
side where I'm gonna be having this
wonderful career but it gets really hard
and it's not the same support as a job
people like all my bosses this my boss
is that this manager but there's a
manager there there's somebody that
manages you there has been teams of
people that set and came up with a plan
of what you're gonna do today
that's an employee now you go into the
other world or now you gotta figure that
out you need a support system of people
that you can bounce ideas off of they
can hold your head when you're crying
you know there's so much more that needs
built into your life that isn't
necessary for a job we're as Americans
you know like then dust your agent
really put us in that that employee
mindset which is fine like that's what
how we survived all these years but now
is we're venturing out the things in
business film is a business so you're
going to film you can't just think i'ma
creative you're also a business because
you're gonna have to do something you're
you're now a commodity at the job your
time is your commodity you're asking can
you pay me for this amount of hours now
you're saying hey I have to build my art
and build myself to be a commodity
enough where something's gonna pay me to
do it and that's a whole new world and
you don't know it yet unless you're
coming from business to business like if
I was you know this awesome business
person that's why some people you see
like Ava Duvernay like she kind of
crossed over and is like whoa she's huge
director out of nowhere
no she was doing this thing already so
if you haven't already been doing it
understand you're gonna come into it at
the elementary level and don't have
these ideas of grandeur like oh I don't
I'm good like no you're not it's okay so
have a very strong support system read a
lot and I don't mean just reading film
books read for something that's gonna
feed your mind because times are gonna
get harder than what you can imagine
and it's not like doomsday but it's like
you've gotta experience some very new
things and that's hard new is hard so
you're experiencing new things you need
some truths to hold on to in those
moments sorry
me personally I be a proverb every day
every single Ermita proverb and I'm
always trying to read some type of book
even if it's like I mean our time like
sometimes I'm not sleeping so I'm not
reading as much like hey I could just
grab this little John Maxwell book and
just read a page okay and then go back
to what I'm doing you know so just
feeding yourself you don't need to feed
yourself as much when you're an employee
mindset but you need to feed yourself
when you're in a position where either
business ownership or where you're now a
commodity you have to feed your self and
feed your something you're getting a
rejection you're getting this you're
getting that and remember the things
that cause someone to quit is not
usually their ability it's usually
something that is happening that they
can't overcome so let's go ahead and
build your up yourself up to where
you're not going to quit when things get
hard cuz things will get hard and then
outside of that timing is everything
unless say I don't know the the whatever
the position is that you have no the
timing of it like if you can you hold
off for one more year when you end you
hold off for one more year you're able
to execute this plan of saving and such
without as much stress you know that's
the timing of that or okay you have a
film idea great have you written it yet
have you talked to the people that are
gonna be helping you in this next moment
if you're gonna be a producer do you
even know what project you'll be working
like I left fully when I was ready to
produce my own feature I was producing
things and doing his it was like pulling
me all types of directions and I live
like that for years it was hard but be
okay if you're in a hard space and
you're like this is too much good
because when you're ready to step out
that too much when you take off one
element you're gonna feel like I can do
this
even more than someone is like right off
the back like I'm quitting I'm going but
everyone's different some people just
like throw
their cares to win and jump into it but
they're jumping into something that
already exists so where are you going
so yes you're ready to go that's great
uncomfortably uncomfortability is a sign
of change you need to change if you're
uncomfortable and I think that's us
that's our what we are created with I
believe in a creator so what you were
created with to say there's something in
me that it's so uncomfortable in this
box I gotta get help
good but be proven about it talk to
people find out where you're going
before you just throw everything away
and say I'm done some people tell me wow
you're so courageous you're so bold like
how did you just how did you do that
especially because when I was leaving
that world my one of my clients offered
me double my salary for an event and
that's where I knew I had to go because
I could have just like Oh more money but
if they offered me double in that entire
time they weren't paying me double I
realized that I will only be paid even
though I was great I will only be paid
by someone how much they the least
amount they can do for my worth but when
I got into film now I'm creating my own
entity now I can go ahead and say I'm
gonna make it what it's worth I'm gonna
make it what it's worth I'm gonna add
the pieces together to make this worth
something
not someone telling me my worth is this
and then saying you know what I'm gonna
subtract you know I'm gonna add so I
think it's really important to just
really know where you're going to be
uncomfortable good but just know how
long can you handle that
uncomfortability is longer than you
think and don't think that it's wasted
time with this job because it's building
something with you that's gonna be
applied in other things I don't care
what the job is you can be working at
Starbucks a hot dog stand whatever
because that juggling perspective of
starting something while doing something
or even just having that ability to
dream while you're under that cloud
that's strength being built in that's
like strength you could pull from later
on and it's residual income like where
it's like hey the things that I went
through in that time period of kind of
doing both I'm able to really pull from
that moment when I'm like this is too
much I'm like wait I don't have to do an
event tomorrow I'm good you know like so
it's it's something again confidence
based in work I already own came things
I already have done those things while
trying to get to the goal yeah but that
also was doing this
I know I can do something I can I can
make things in my own hands I can
achieve greatness I can do these things
so do that prove it to yourself do a
confidence check like you know like am i
confident enough to do this and then go
off and do it and then it's like without
refrain without looking back with no
second like you know like this is my
plan B no only have a plan a once you
get there but don't hear people say that
and be ignorant to the fact that they
got there you can't start it like no
plan a like I mean no plan B either I'm
only playing any but wait hold on how do
you get there you have to be pretty
heavy wise you have to make decisions
you have to make plans and then you can
cast all that away and jump in with both
feet
you